That's my goal, to make them
happy all the time. When he died,
was it weird not having a
person? Oh man, it was so man,
it was just emptiness.
It was just,
and then people who we thought with our
friends and that we say we're going to
be good too. They started when he died,
they had started going in for the kill.
You just want to ask me for means.
Well it seemed like you and Kevin Rooney
had a good combination at the beginning
when he died,
when when customers,
we didn't know what we're going to do.
They're thinking about
getting rid of Kevin and,
and I was thinking I didn't
want to be with nobody else.
Everybody was comfortable with Kevin and
the style and the way we were going to,
I didn't want to be an oil, so I
said, no, let's just keep Kevin. Yeah.
And Kevin was a great change for me.
Very well respected trainer. Yeah.
It was a good relationship.
Like the way it worked in the beginning
it looked like, but then like all things,
you know, Kevin used to train me and
then fighting our finances and the it.
Oh really? Yeah. Wow. Wow.
And this was all like w w was
he training you? Um, before,
before Kostayan as well? Well yeah. How
many, how many years before Christ died?
Was he like holding myths for you and
if the couple, but he knew you well.
Did he watch well?
Did he watch fights with you as well?
Did you or were you watching
those fights to fight the,
with Liam started
training with each other.
We started watching fights
together because you're star,
that was the other thing to your style.
The way you would come out
was so reminiscent of old
fighters and when you come
out and no socks on black shoes.
Wow. That would think in my mind.
I think it was a lot about
gladiator NBA toughing it out.
Another thing now look at it now for
looking at Philly. Philly kid. Thank you.
Tough. I don't think I look at it.
Thanks Tom. Where you are tough man.
I know what you're saying. I know
what you're saying. But you were,
when you fought Marvis
Fraser on what does the ABC,
I remember watching that fight
going. Holy Shit. Holy Shit.
It was like being locked into a ring
with a tornado. That was wild day. Yeah.
That was a tough kid. That was your
peak. That was when it was peak. Scary.
You know, you were coming up and
everybody was just terrified.
It was just a wild thing to watch man
to be a part of it. To be you. Yeah.
One of the, I make my mentor happy though.
That was my main goal and fighting.
It's a powerful goal.
Yeah.
Did you ever try to go back and get
hypnotized after all that's over to try to
maybe calm down that part of your
mind? Um, I never did. I had to do the,
I think helped me out the total.
Yeah, it is definitely that stuff.
We helped me out. Did we'd help you
out at all? I'm pretty much, yeah.
You know what I mean? But it had to do it
every day. I had to do it all the time.
Right.
Do it all the time then yeah,
if I went to another country and I didn't
have my weed up at insane, they what?
No, we I going to be here a
couple of days a week. A month,
get the hell out of here.